this week we're going to look at a
specific application of artificial
intelligence in a virtual human agent
and we'll have to present from Japan we
have the startup company cougar and we
have the CEO mr. su Shi Ishi
and we have the chief blockchain
architect mr. Kanzaki ishiguro oh and
they have self introduction so I'll let
them do the self introductions I think
you'll see it on the next slide but each
person will give prepared remarks then
we'll all three come up here and do a
panel discussion that will be very
interactive with you
thanks for coming and you she's on the
floor is yours
yeah thank you ah okay letting the
country's about Alex Northey called
connect song it's a pronunciation is
correct oh by the way do you know czar
keyboard control please raise our hand
okay connectome is nervous system in
human brain we we can see there are
something and we can hear something we
can touch something right but at the
same time we we understand very complex
situation and this is because of connect
on in your brain so that's why our
product name is also connect on because
our technology is combining IOT other
your five senses and rock chain is as
your novice and brain is as you are AI
and of course robotics is right your
body so and that's the eyes connect on
me
okay this is today's index first what
interface do we need in the near future
it is my part for twenty or twenty four
five minutes and second part is how to
ensure the variability of data and AI it
is cause a key part after me yeah let me
explain by myself I'm co-founder of
Connect phone and CEO of Cougar Kouga is
Tokyo based startup and Kouga is always
developing combining cutting-edge
technologies such as IOT and the I am AI
am AR we are like that and my background
is I was developing rice cakes are
changing in IBM or unlocked in black
thing is one biggest issue site just
like Amazon okay and the connectome is
the next-generation interface combining
a I am a R and the blockchain so first
we will show you some video from movie
it is a as you know it's from bread
runner Zara yeah a human right a is
coming
it was a day would you rate me you don't
make you feel better yes
and it is very similar to our vision our
vision is to realize this kind of human
agent and that compared to current AI
and budget resistance and current AI is
for specific purpose and mainly for
using playing music and some searching
as you know and in the future like bread
runner
the AI is communicate just like human
and it's very very different and why now
let me explain there are the timing and
as you know interface is changing from
everyday and from PC and the smartphone
and small speaker and the important
thing is according to changing the
interface the data is also increase
increase and increase and at the same
time the data is changing to privacy
data right if you use computer the
privacy data is maybe your browser
browser data or something like that but
if you use smartphone you upload your
private photo and also you use very
often Seoul's behavior data is abroad
and also GPS as well and for small
speaker as you know small speaker it's
on your room over your your office it's
more more privacy data
and at the same time there are situation
is changing and as you know the mega
player like Facebook and Amazon and
Google has big big data big privacy data
and maybe you you knows Amazon AXA
suddenly Duffy and very very very
strange but nobody know as a running
data and the AI model it's closed
brought box and of course Facebook has
many many trouble recently and at the
same time you know the unspecified
devices will be connect in the future so
this means that unspecified devices will
connect and the data connection will be
real time the air time means every
devices have to analyze or execute some
some program program so that means we
have to create some structure to make
variability AI and data and and the
privacy is also coming so people expect
more rich interface and more rich more
their time and rich contents so it's not
a timing so we are now developing the
interface it's called a part of human
agent let me show you the demo
they didn't hang out and now it's
contractor Maya's answers the corner and
if they're connected
a priori at all she knows the street I
do not do
Jupiter and this appears of monitor
since moving to the air and at the same
time but a human detects object such as
chair tables and if see a possum cross
as possible in the airspace
Alfonzo yeah chair and of course I can
talk to her
and now
an agitating on smartphone but we are
testing folks smart grants its more
famous and it is called big Martinez not
and bother ko no energy to design by
yourself
yes and as a as a also demo this is a
the person try to move it to this with
project to the possum
dire straits
what did there
I'm now walking to the office
Sinatra
also depicted objects
I'm very good about
no no no
again
we have lights
and for the guys well attended
yes this is what a human agent yes as
you see the body human agent processes
sight and sound right human and
understanding space and object able to
talk very smoothly and we are time
reaction and have feelings and the
memory and emotion and of course
connected to IOT devices and this is a
big difference from other device right
there our speaker and budget uma has
pasted the expression facial expression
body expression so butter human express
complex situation to the user and it is
accept decry and positive negative right
sir and this is a potential of human
right interface this is the combat
conversation investigation yeah when
asking a person using a bunch of human
compared to the key only boys and the
best bones rate is increased and the
response time also increase its it's
very impressive and this one is for
autistic patients talk to about your
humor in in the in the investigation
sixty percent or page patient respond
that it is easier to talk with larger
human more than real people yeah it's
incredible and this is different
approach of connect phone and you know
this is Amazon and Google is has a big
data and this is a comprehension AI
means if you understand something human
and the bottles or bicycle or cats or
something like that
in that case if you have big data it's
very easy easy to understand so that's
why Google and Amazon is mainly using a
machine learning and they're very strong
mainly answer is just one and this part
is gaming gaming company is very strong
remember if you play the game you can
feel your teammate is really exists and
you're an enemy is very exists so so so
that you are your teammate is care about
you and enemy try to kill you or try to
destroy the world that's fine you can
enjoy the world so this is very
different
so our connectome is combining these two
technologies so input comprehension is
using machine learning and the decision
making and sharing humor like reading is
just right chapter and gaming AI okay so
let's talk about the budget human
architecture overview bottle human is
structured from four blocks first one is
input and complete complete
comprehension and the second one is
processing and sunrise meditation and
Ross one is output
it's a little bit complicated yes I fold
in put a vision is for example the
object detection and shield face and
pose and sound these boys and bacteria
background music touches haptics now
these senses rise up and the output side
is human body expression on face
expression Alexa and also IOT devices
and subs APs and there are some middle
range is very complex processing and
make tissue and it is from unconscious
and emotion and personality and behavior
remix brain explain details
yes for example if you detect this cat
cat in that part cat is understanding
and after that unconscious area is
working in that time as semantic memory
is working it is cut at the same time
episodic memory is working if you if you
love cut the emotion is changing too
happy and pressure but if you if you
don't like cut emotionally it's sad or
angry like that and at the same time the
personality is selected personality
means from you skier and the URL or or
something like that for example if you
see the cat and Europe cat
so Europe card captain you you you want
to rough or very happy but if your
personality if you are always deception
East in the so
you'll be mind maybe it's difficult to I
can't I can't rap or something like that
it's connected and so by the human
control their feelings and after that
this decision is made
petitions are executed and the behavior
3 means what kind of body action is
should be should be done should be
executed and finally it is connected and
output is will be execute right is that
yes it is for categorize and fourth
great great part is machine learning and
much the point is machine learning is
only one or two answers but for this
green or blue blue blue zone is hub
several answers several options and the
green one is we are using game method
and game AI and the green one is our
original human human based science yes
so in so vital human agent is will be
changing to part of their society I
think so in that time the use case is
increase increase in English like
entertainment and assistant and spaces
and also you can develop your original
budget humi isn't we we will provide
SDKs develop our designer or a AI
developer can create by the human agent
on the market price and it is used for
receptionist and car guide or game
entertainment
it's a etc and especially you know the
definition of car and mobility will
change a you know car will be autonomous
car this means you don't need to drive
so in the case car is changing your room
so but your human agent is also expected
in this space so let me show you the
demo
all right something is going to music
good morning Jennifer good morning
Bonnie looking forward to today's music
- Maya oh yeah I'm so ready to see food
and it's sunny around the venue oh
that's great nice sounds also but it
will rain yeah let's play your favorite
music
now thank you
[Music]
I like it thanks I have good taste
some of you don't have something to
drink but do you want to buy them at
convenience stores stay there it's ok
thank you
have you had your breakfast I don't know
I haven't do you want to get some
breakfast
ichiran ramen restaurant Jennifer it's
very fun of 15 minutes from here
oh it's all around me try that yeah
sounds good to me too
yeah let's go okay
[Music]
the grass on why should you mind enough
to the driver okay I know
yeah like that so it's a summary and
battle humor humor agree interface
creates trust trusting relationship
between human and AI yes and of course a
multiple use case expand the on demand
is increased and diverse diversity
education of ehh got growing up and so
AI its growth area is so many AI will be
we need so in that in in that case it is
important to harbor mekinese to create
the durability of data and AI so in the
spot kisaki will explain together thank
you very much thank you hi did you guys
feel like having your own virtual human
yeah I really do hope so
and this this time we are going to cover
how blockchain nature the reliability of
data and hey does anybody know what is
blockchain is can you please raise your
hand okay that's good that's good
and no sir I want to ask them how many
of you have used AI in a daily life not
many what about like some Siri how we
have use Siri I for my iPhone okay
that's good so the question is how can
you prove that those AI are safe to use
or how can you prove that those AI is
not sending your private private data to
somebody else so I'm going to point it
out the problem so I'm going to cover
the part
my name is Kazuaki and I'm chief boxing
architect at Cougars in the building
platform called connectome no sir I
started my career as a DJ in the
Hollywood
when I used to and they're kind of like
self-taught programming now after coming
back to Japan I joined a couple you know
startup company and they are jointed
quicker in the building about blockchain
apart for so let's do a quick review of
AI timeline just giving you some history
of AI so it's been a while
it started as artificial intelligence
back in the 1950s okay I think I should
start up here right okay down back there
that was really simple it's called Ruby
say I
and then the first breakthrough came up
in the 1980s which is called machine
learning what it does is subset of
artificial intelligence and the next the
biggest breakthrough came out after 2010
it's a subset of machine learning
aka deep learning so after deepening
came out everyone start developing their
own AI okay so what is the AI what it
does inside of AI
so once after deep learning you get the
a I just like this in other words it's a
trained model and then trained model
doesn't do anything by itself
you're gonna you're going to have to
have our input and then based on those
input AI is gonna give you some output
very simple so input has input is going
to comprehend for example you get some
picture or some conversation or some
text or whatever the same is and then AI
is going to detect something and then
they're going to give you some output
which is reactions or evaluation but
between these two layers there is a
merrill layers we call it
decision-making process
and this is where magic happens because
no one knows what is going on no one
wants to share inside the middle layers
because that's that's there
I don't know business model or that's
the key OPI and then this middle layer
and input side has a lots of problems
causing today now I'm going to point it
out one by one the first one is black
box data I think at the shoulders
emissions but I'm going to deep dive so
if you want to create some AI which is
very precise and high accuracy you're
going to require you're going to have a
lots of data sets maybe a hundred times
more you you imagines I don't know maybe
more and then data is not always clean
data so you have to have someone to
clean those data sets or you're going to
have some big database to store those
data that's why data is really valuable
and then once you have valuable data
sets you don't want to share to somebody
else because it has evaluated right and
there is going to cause a tile data
style and know so black books because of
course you don't want to share to
somebody else and then the economist
already put it out Dara is new oil in a
2000 and those tech giants already
working hard to collect in those data
sets and as you already know there's
always problem so AI is not trustworthy
I think Amazon Alexa bug is very famous
one and then the next one is the Google
home bug which is they actually
recording the home conversation and then
send it to somebody else
which is
on their address book which is super
scary there's no private privacy at all
and also the uber autonomous car
accident maybe you might have heard or
not autonomous during the test of
autonomous car driving they kill they
hit the pedestrians and then pedestrian
died unfortunately but they don't reveal
the problem is there any books or any I
don't know what was going on they just
press release ok we'll fix it don't
worry about it you are now safe to use
our eyes but we should know what was
going on inside but there's no way so
that's problem so we we have developed
some technology called
we have developed some application yeah
call gene flow which is a system that
records the learning and the execution
history of AI in the blockchain and
ensures a reliability of AI the gene
flow name because we can track and trace
the cross history so it works like a
family tree and the ones you have get
the parents AI you can you know once you
got newer transfer model you can always
like trace parents models so that's why
we named it gene flow so before we get
into the GFO we want a quick review i
want to quick review the boxing what is
blotchiness
that's good the blockchain is literally
it's a chain of blocks which contain the
list of Records transactions ok
and it's decentralized and the
distribute and public digital laser the
most important part is the ones
transaction stored in the block it'sa
Mirabal which means you cannot change
once you have
create some records and since it's a
distributor ledger
once you have the least some data our
blocks
ain't never gone because somebody else
has it so that's why it's secure the
network the other important part is
smart contract it's simply the computer
program stored the inside of the box
chain because it stores in the
blockchain it's also aamir able and
distributed which means you cannot
change any cause once you have created
those smart contract so that's why it's
so secure right ok I would like to go
over more and more because I'm a
blockchain architect but that's another
just I guess ok so how do you feel our
pioneer correcto
mainly connector I mean gene flow will
be applied in the comprehension in our
side connectome has produced some
virtual human agent and the core
technology on the comprehension side is
used by gene flow
okay so what why you have to have
blockchain technology in the gene flow
can we create by centralized server or
can we create like Amazon or Google so
let's compare the one in the red part is
a centralized server just like tech
giant's do they store the data in the
black books and then also they store
some algorithm because they don't want
to share somebody else and then they
install it into some AI or devices for
example Amazon Alexa or I don't know
iPhone Siri or any some kinds of AI
install devices but they release okay we
have open datasets or per algorithm we
have installed into the devices but
there is no way to prove that right on
the other hand the decentralized if we
apply some blockchain technology we have
learning data sets you can always check
what kind of data are there or what
color go the mother also we have traced
the history of learning data and are
with them and then once we have
installed into devices like this you can
always trace because of the transaction
histories so we have AI or machine
learning data sets algorithm and then
train model so once we have created some
data and we stored all the data an
algorithm and train model into the
boxing and then if you have another data
sets in other data sets and training are
above them we all store into the
blockchain that's why you can trace the
history of a growth of AI that's why
it's so secure and it's open data set so
you can always check back if you got a
new iPhone okay what kind of AI argue
the mother you can always check back if
you are using a box in technology okay
so let's coming back to AI outline okay
now we have Empire or comprehension
inside comprehension AI are safe to use
okay what about these two the middle and
the output layer can we open those
layers I guess we can do but no one does
that's why causing a problem sorry I
proved number two is are good this is
what it looks like on the middle layer
and the output layer so decision-making
action process is simple like this if my
AI or china are with train tomorrow how
received input a input something and
detect something and do this very simple
but from our point of view it looks
something like this it's in the black
books and that it seems like magic is
happening inside of AI you only get the
output right and this is what happens
when some January Saskia Sophia the
product I will destroy the humans but we
don't know why she made those kind of
decisions right because my heart
wouldn't say so so this is a problem
this is scary right so we set some kind
of use cases to tackle this problem
which is the smart space use cases so
for example if my trend model have
detect serial person without something
to drink
do something so please be careful
watching the this output part what she
is going to do what our AI is going to
do and this part is our meeting room and
people sitting right detect the person
and then the some you know post
detections this is a computer vision by
the way and then this is our office and
they detect in a bottle water or tea and
we have a person the supporter
so two person came in this sick
kochira the number of people have been
increased in the conference room they
may stay long because they have seen it
why don't you take some drinks for them
you need two of them because we have two
more people sure we're - mother bina yes
please bring two bottles okay thank you
thank you come cheering so yeah she
detected two more person in a meeting
room but they don't have any you know
something to drink
so Rai detect someone we know office and
ask him to bring some bottles okay good
job okay and then this is our
architecture of our small home use cases
so we have sensor to detect some someone
in the room and then we once we have
take some pictures or some videos when
through the AI nodes and we have image
and a metadata which is we have person
or sitting or bottles or whatever does
the metadata here and then we sent it to
the master server and then store in the
blockchains here okay and the most
important part is smart contract here
and also this part so this is an input
part if they're Syrian without something
to drink
let the virtual human find someone in
the office and suggest a person to bring
borrow we store these algorithm into the
smart contract so that everyone can
check after you know the virtual human
made decisions what was going on inside
of her you can check on the smart
contract because it's stored in the
blockchain in the public leisure so
coming back to this outline it's now
safe to use everyone everything input
middle layer and output layers and this
is our virtual human measure having you
know
ensure the reliability so in a future
well as after she explained we are going
to provide some SDK so everyone can have
your own virtual human you can develop
by yourself while you can purchase from
somewhere else and are we going to have
tons of many virtual human agent which
is good ok ok ok so but once we have
lots of lots of virtual human agent the
next question is how can how can we find
my perfect virtual human agent how or I
need some virtual humor age'
for a specific form I use cases or
something or some of the virtual humor
agent have that algorithm or if you if
your developers that's ok but if we're
not developers I cannot read some code
and I didn't know you know how they're
going to act how can we do so the next
challenge is how to evaluate a virtual
humor agent with diversity for for the
classic classic approach is using a
search engine like Google or Amazon's is
it still safe to use or maybe not so
this is an example using a centralized
search engine ok we search let's find
best self-driving car AI or virtual
human agent and then though is we have
100,000 results and then they have some
lists of a search result but problem
here is sponsors content has always
priority they always coming on the top
or they have some they have applied some
techniques to search engine optimization
or we are
No some black box filter filtering our
inside of a search engine
or as they pointed out they have five
stars AI but we how can we trust those
feedbacks so we are going to use the
decentralized evaluation system which is
called connector marketplace it's
decentralized market plus market
platform for virtual human agent and any
developers can create their own virtual
human functions or interfaces and
marketplace is maintained by community
because community is stronger than
economies right they have mission vision
to to maintain these communities and
inside of this marketplace we have we
are going to apply some incentive
mechanism to maintain these networks and
also sell civility and cryptographic
proof ok so this is a incentive
mechanism example of incentive mechanism
created by Joe Mangal from some
blockchain researchers and we have
creator and users and investors and then
these three parties work together in the
costly because currently their equity
and work is separated in the company
right
but in this crypto economic activities
put these two into one big things so
this is how community works with our
incentive mechanism and the one example
of a search engine in a decentralized
way is called token carry registry it's
also called TCR insured
for example if you are virtual human
developers we have created some new
virtual human to sell it on the
marketplace so if we want to sell it
into the marketplace to be on these
lists which kinda like you know search
engine results you have to have steak
some tokens to be on the list but there
is no control
after you propose the new virtual human
who's going to evaluate there's another
party's which is virtual human critics
or enthusiast so they're going to vote
this proposal with a with talks taking
the tokens so if they lie they're going
to lose some tokens so there is no
incentive to tell a lie or if you don't
agree with these Nooyi new proposals you
can challenge to find better virtual
human in the market okay the virtual
human you have created is cool but not
precisely enough not looking good or
there are better algorithms in the
market I will find it so I'm going to
challenging you staking whether talking
and of course virtual humor agent users
can are free to read these these lists
and this is how community works in a
decentralized way so as I told you
communities very stronger than your
economies so we are really focusing on
Community Development recently we have
done a virtual human hackathon with some
other project from belem cold ocean
protocol so we have set the selling
point the best virtual human customer
service and now all the developer
apply to be on the list which is small
functional root functions or whatever
and then some other party is going to
vote okay I need these function on the
best virtual human customer service and
stuff like that and then it came out
really good brilliant and also we we
have done lots of Community Development
all over the world so we are focusing on
all the developers although all the
people is going to use our or our
marketplace to develop their own virtual
human and sell it to somebody else
without trusting us or without trusting
and other parties so that's the future
that we are looking at so I'm very
excited to provide this service in the
future so that's it for me thank you
very much
great
[Applause]
you